question to you guys oh I haven't said
that for a while question question to
you guys
how long has been since I said that all
right how much do you think First
Impressions actually matter
um
that's not a scenario yeah how's it like
situation we're in right I mean it's
definitely important I mean there's a
there's a whole reason why you know
everyone and their mother always says
like oh you know make sure your first
impression is good because that could
last your entire friendship if you you
know if they continue to pursue it and
everything like that but also you know
I've had moments where I've met someone
the first impression wasn't you know the
most like 10 out of 10 favorable thing
ever but oh yeah
like this guy right here but you know
eventually over time you know you give
her the benefit of the doubt and yeah
you know you end up forming a very great
friendship right so and I've had
complete opposite instances of like the
first impression was like a 10 out of 10
like oh yeah I'm gonna be friends with
this person so hard yeah and then a
couple of times after you kind of start
to show the the real side I guess
because they didn't show it on their
first impression and then you're just
like oh yeah you want you're not really
as cool as the first time I met you yeah
okay counter question then okay to that
question because I feel like this is uh
this is like the the whole first
impression thing is it's kind of like
hinged on another way that I at least I
view conversation right is it like I
feel like a friendship isn't like formed
or at least isn't like uh like real
let's say I mean you're like your
acquaintances in my mind but until
there's like something like shared
information then like you both share
things yeah and that it's like an equal
sharing of uh maybe personal information
or no you'd have to be like here's my
bank account detail as well
dark secret yeah but it's like sharing
of of like maybe emotions that could be
vulnerable or maybe uh just just kind of
saying hey I trust you to this other
person and then they say it back and
it's like yeah I can hang out with
someone for 10 times and if I feel like
I just still don't know them or don't
know anything about them it's like it
doesn't mean [__] but someone someone
could overshare on the first time I'd be
like that's too much because now I feel
like you're too willing to share this
and so it's kind of like it's kind of
like how do you share information and
I've got what my question's gonna be
it's more gonna be like okay how do you
how do you then judge
what that first impression means I guess
I've I've actually I've actually uh I've
actually gone
I've actually got a yeah I I I kind of
do understand what you're trying to say
yeah yeah
um because I've had this exact same it's
like a dance yeah if the person's too
closed off yeah you're like well we're
not friends yeah I mean if they're too
open you're like this is too much yeah
and it's just like how do you make the
perfect first impression
right and okay so I've thought about
this a lot and my Approach has changed I
guess as I've gotten older so when I was
younger I'd say like when you know when
I was in like my early 20s I I wouldn't
even say I'd met my first real friends
until I was about the age of 24 24 25
actually so I would say actually pretty
late I actually found what my meaning of
like oh I understand what people means
when they say a true friend right so
before I would wait I would be way more
conscious about trying to set the
perfect good like first impression like
in my mind uh like as you said maybe
trying to think
I wouldn't worry about how it's coming
off I was yeah I was like I'm just gonna
be me and I'm sure that I know I'm not
like a dick whenever people so I'm like
I'll I'll be okay yeah uh I mean I'll
just worry about just having a good time
yeah and I think back then it was
because I was just because I didn't
really have many friends I would call
you know true friends I would just try
to befriend everywhere yeah yeah you
know you you trying yeah I was exactly
the same I think I think that's very
common when you're like in your teens
you everyone for the most part unless
you're like a true [__] like I think
everyone just wants to be a people
pleaser everyone wants everyone to like
me yeah exactly how do I do that I give
off a first impression that I kind of
gauge maybe this is the kind of person
that this person wants to see in me
exactly right but yeah they're gone yeah
I mean I didn't think too much about
whether I want actually wanted to be
their friend I just wanted more friends
you know so I wanted to say I just
wanted people to like you yeah exactly
you just want people to like you you
know that's still that's that that side
of me is still like never gotten away
it's never nice to think that [__] that
person definitely hates me now or
something it's never a nice feeling but
um you know as I've got an older as I've
you know have more friends that I feel
comfortable with and everything I just
find out that you know I think this must
be an age thing where you just find you
just have less patience uh with people
you know and you have less care about
trying to be friends with everyone
so now that I'm at this stage I think
First Impressions actually mean a lot
right because sometimes you do you kind
of like you do you kind of tell off like
not even like even if you don't talk to
someone do you sometimes like see
someone in like a new group a table and
you're like I think I would vibe with
you and I don't know why do you have do
you ever have that no no for sure yeah
yeah yeah and normally like my kind of
like your my like sixth sense that I've
guessed like you've you know honed over
time I've kind of like been able to pick
up on like subtle subconscious cues
where I'm like I think I would vibe with
this person based on the way they said
this one sentence or the way they talk
and I don't know why but I just have I
just have that feeling and most of the
time it ends up being true right uh and
it's not really about you know sending
because it's not really about have they
said a good first impression it's more
about just you kind of get like the same
you kind of get the energy of someone
now that we've hang out with like enough
people IRL yeah you're probably I think
it's I think it's the due to the fact
that like you know you're able to kind
of you've because you've met so many
different people with so many different
personality traits and you've eventually
seen how those personality traits end up
when they you know show their true
selves I guess when you become friends
with them right I think just from that
you're you have a better understanding
as you get older of like you know
especially when it comes to First
Impressions at least with me I can kind
of tell if someone's giving off a first
impression
because they're either actually like
that in real life yeah or they're just
trying to show the best parts of
themselves yeah like there's there's
some First Impressions where I'm just
like okay I know you're like trying to
be friendly with me but I can just I
have a Vibe you are not this kind of
person yeah like in actuality right and
I don't know why and most of the time
I've got that right where I'm just like
oh yeah you you were kind of like just
trying to show off your first impression
that I would like because you really
wanted to be friends with me and I
appreciate that yeah but at the end of
the day I'm gonna be friends with people
who are honest with me when it comes to
their personality how do you know if
you're right how do you know if how do
you know if you're right I said use it
like most of the time you're right when
you're like I got a bad impression of
them how would you know you're right if
you did not trust or befriend someone I
don't again I've I've I think for me
personally I've just been in so many
situations where I've given them the
benefit of the doubt and then at the end
of the day they've betrayed me in some
way right and you know I've had a lot of
people backstab me in my life you know
because I was just trying to be friends
with everyone I gave everyone the
benefit of the doubt yeah but now that
I'm approaching 30 I've just gone to the
point where I'm like I don't have
[__] patience for this like yeah if
you don't if I don't get the vibe from
you that I'm gonna be be good friends
with you you know whether that be the
first time meeting or the 10th month
time meeting or the 100th time meeting
then I'm not even going to bother
pursuing this friendship yeah you know
and at the end of the day like I think
that's because I've seen enough people
now and I've seen enough personality
differences where I have a much better
understanding now in my life compared to
when I was in like high school of like
okay are you being legit right now are
you actually showing the side of me that
is you or are you showing the side of me
that I want you to see yeah if that
makes sense yeah because the the way I
that we are the way I approach it is you
know I only have I guess a certain
amount of social energy
so if if I get like the kind of like
vibe that I think like no nowadays if
I'm like I think it's gonna take a lot
of social energy to hang out with this
one person and then I hang out with them
like two or three times and I'm like
that was kind of exhausting not for not
from not because of anything they did
wrong just because I just think our
energies are like a little bit different
and sometimes when I'm like some of you
just don't gel with yeah sometimes you
just don't gel with someone and I that
used to bother me a lot because I'm like
I want to gel with everyone and now I'm
just like I gel with the people I gel
with because I can't help the person I
am you know and uh like I'm not gonna
change my personality for every other
different type of Personality trait just
because I want to be friends with them
yeah it's like I want to just be me and
if you don't [__] with me and my
personality then I'm not gonna bother
trying to show the best side of me
because that's who I am and if you don't
want to be friends with me that way hey
you know what there's plenty of fish in
the sea yeah there's plenty of other
people you can gel with and it just so
happens that that person is not me and
that's fine you know yeah where do you
think where do you think people can find
friends in this day and age because
that's that's because like like you said
we are very we're very lucky right we're
very lucky to have a job where we get to
meet a lot of people a lot of times
Anime conventions Anime conventions
honestly for as much as much as we we
clown on Anime conventions like I think
especially for people who like anime and
like weeb culture like I genuinely think
that is the best place to meet people
because it's like
shared interests yeah spaces you know
whether that be like you know any kind
of convention or like any kind of meet
up or you know just something IRL I
think is so [__] important for
especially kids in this day and age that
you know do I think I think the
blurriness of online friends and real
friends quote unquote is slowly getting
blurred by the day especially with like
the younger generation because to them
online friends are their real friends
yeah in a lot of instances right and you
know maybe it that is true but I think
again as as Conor was saying like you
need you need that human touch dude you
gotta you gotta you gotta interact with
people yeah yeah exactly there's always
like because now that I've had a few
experiences now where I've just
completely moved to a new city
um sometimes not knowing anyone it's
it's always like hard whenever you move
somewhere new especially you have like
if you have like established friendship
group back home you moved somewhere
totally new and you're like [__] I've
got to start from zero and find a new
friendship group here and that that
takes a lot of time and that takes a lot
of like energy I think the biggest the
Japan was more easy because like I had
like Geeks plus I had you guys uh the
hardest one for me was actually probably
Thailand uh because when I moved to
Thailand uh me and Sydney we we knew
family but I did not have any like Thai
friends yeah at all and you know
my my experience with that was I would
just have to go to as many meetups as
possible whether it be like you know
there's there's a lot of different
websites that you can use for different
meetups for certain specific let's say
you know niches or interests and I think
doing that is such like such a big
important factor into trying like giving
yourself the opportunity to make friends
yeah because if you never give if you
never go out of your comfort zone if you
are too lazy to just go out and put
yourself out there and meet people that
you have you know like you don't know if
you're gonna be friends or not
um then you're not gonna make friends
and I think this needs to be said as
well of like I feel there's this when we
say like you know you should go to like
meetups or like conventions to like make
friends like I I think there's this like
weird social pressure to be like oh okay
I'm going to this convention this
weekend if I don't come back with at
least x amount of friends friends then
like I've wasted my time or whatever
which I think is just like not true like
I I think like the whole social pressure
of like I have to make friends again
here's the problem is if you're going if
you're going anywhere to
make friends you're already kind of
setting yourself up for failure that's
how think about every friendship you've
ever had it probably hasn't come from
you trying to make sure yeah yeah yeah I
mean you know there is no friendship
that has started with let can we be
friends let's be friends let's be
friends that's that's not how
friendships start friendships start
naturally just like you don't have to
ask the question it's just a mutual
agreement of like yeah your call you
think I'm cool hey I guess we're friends
now yeah and like I feel like even just
going to any kind of Meetup or
convention and maybe not necessarily
coming back with a concrete result of
like I made this many friends you know
maybe you it might have been zero I
think it's still good to go to those
kinds of places because you learn so
many skills to just like interact with
people and to like you know get in the
position of naturally making friends
because yeah you know again like no
friendship starts with the question of
can we be friends well that's not how it
works it's less about making friends
more about just finding people that you
can hang out with yeah because I feel
like yes another thing about making
friends online is that talking to people
talking to people online is easy mode
that's that's like that's like easy mode
right that's like socializing with
training skills uh with training wheels
in a sense right
um because you know when you're online
you can kind of like if it's via text
for for one then you can uh you can have
the time to think about what you're
gonna say it's the equivalent to passing
notes in a classroom yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's not communicating and uh again if
even if you're on call you can be
concentrating on something else and it's
just you know it's not always the same
kind of like Vibe uh as being there in
real life so yeah I mean I I think I was
I was firmly in that camp for a very
long time
um and then I guess just hanging out
with mouse has changed my opinion a lot
on it so I'm like okay well here's
somebody who just can't yeah leave their
house yeah and it's like okay would I
ever say that's not a real friendship no
absolutely not okay so it's like then
it's a situation of like okay well is
this just like a is I just how I view
this entire situation is it was I wrong
or am I just bending my the way I view
it just for one case I'm like it's kind
of weird because I think that it's it's
I think it's a personal preference of
each kind of person like individual you
meet like there probably some people who
you're fine talking to online and
there's probably some people who you're
like I don't really gel talking to you
on Discord like I never [__] talk to
you guys online on the call yeah I know
I'm like hang out with you guys in
person like I don't want to call you
guys yeah yeah so I think it's it's a
really odd distinction and I don't know
what that means or how that interacts
with my beliefs but yeah I thought it
was interesting that's what I mean like
I feel like because now those kinds of
friendships uh are getting more common
especially among younger people like I
feel that line is slowly getting blurred
to the point where it's like maybe
online friends are becoming real friends
just based on different you know like
prerogatives right like you know yeah in
the case like Mouse like you know she is
an online friend yes but she is also
your actual real friend as well right
yeah so it's like where's the
distinction in that I just think that if
if I had only had online friends up
until that point I would use a lot of
um I'd lose a lot of the ability to
learn like what I think are important
social skills uh you know like reading
body language reading you know when I
say something did they react badly to
that yeah knowing that like those little
cues or making enough eye contact you
know these are stuff that comes in handy
when you're you know when we're if we're
ever filming something and there's a
crew and it's like all right let's you
know like you you don't want to be a
dick like yeah be nice to everyone like
how do you how do you socialize people
in a meaningful way
um you know and if whenever I had jobs
or whatever I had to talk to people all
the time and it was like if I didn't
learn social skills before that I would
have been very very unprepared for that
and possibly have made a bad impression
or maybe I would have not been you know
wouldn't have got another job etc etc
you know a lot of a lot of the stuff
especially like voice acting and stuff
like that was all a lot of connections
and making good Impressions and it's
like okay a lot of the stuff you want to
do probably requires you to have great
social skills and if you've the only
experience you've had is via online you
might not be well prepared to then be in
a situation uh in in real life and be
kind of left your own social skills
because maybe you're just missing out on
things you didn't even consider about
right like and it's it's tough because
it's like okay well how do you how do
you learn that yeah because there's a
lot of situations where like you know I
think
people people have a lot more anxiety
nowadays yeah for a number of reasons
and it's like how do you
you know if you're an anxious person how
do you how do you learn those things how
do you push yourself to be uh to go out
more and interact more I don't know yeah
for me it was just trial by fire oh
honestly it's I because I I had massive
social anxiety and you know people might
not believe me but I was like that quiet
kid yeah uh I I was I I you know talking
from experience I was that [__] quiet
kid in high school I had like basically
no friends
um and I just like going into University
I was like I'm kind of tired of this
life I'm just [__] tired I'm so sh
I'm so socially anxious and I just
realized that if I don't commit to this
100 I'm not gonna commit to this at all
which is why I went to that phase where
I'm just gonna throw myself in every
awkward social situation I can think of
and there have been
so there are so many different uh
memories I have wiped from my mind uh
because it I was just you have to [__]
up
I was an awkward little [__] and
sometimes I just stay awake at night and
I just think about that one [__]
party I went to and I said that thing to
that guy and I was just like oh my God
why did I say that you know I've thought
about this so many times and I've always
said to people every time like people
worry way more about how they're coming
off than how you're coming off yeah
unless you say something [__] up like
a lot of people are just more worried
about how like again what they're saying
so like a lot of the time when you've
said something that maybe you thought
was really cringe they probably didn't
even give a [__] they were like what
yeah well maybe they thought it was
funny yeah they like pretty much paid no
mind to it they're like oh yeah I guess
you did you did do that one crazy thing
but I totally just didn't care like you
know what I mean like I think it's easy
to get in your own head with this kind
of stuff but also it's it's I guess you
can't just be like just don't be anxious
just do it just get over it I mean the
things
let's just go out you have to you have
to go out there and it sucks because you
know everything can always be traced
back to like when you're a kid and like
did you know uh did you get the right
experiences or yeah were you brought up
in a family that encouraged that kind of
stuff yeah was your brain chemistry just
were you just born different like was it
saying that you were just you were gonna
struggle with your entire life like
these are all valid valid questions